se scrivo nel titolo che il gioco si
chiama live sono arrivata in diretta ma
non era diretta quindi va beh possiamo
apprezzare già subito una qualità nel
menu principale che fa accapponare la
pelle
vabbè get the candy va bene pressing su
internet
ok ma chi e bel gioco con che musica di
sottofondo me lo stai dicendo tra
l'altro va beh lasciando stare i salti
chilometrici che fa questo bambino
pressa z to attack a questa la mia arma
da distruzione di massa sono proprio un
killer fosse stato e la madonna quattro
casinò c'è qua sopra tatran dovuto fare
una pila gigante per bloccarmi il
passaggio perché salto un chilometro c'è
ma vi sembra normale sta roba
quanto a sproporzionato sto gioco a
questi sono i lego non ci devo andare
sopra va bene una ma ragazza io gioco
del battlefield cosa gioco dell'anno rag
ora vado quanto sproporzionato ma per
ragazzi è il giorno più brutto che abbia
mai vincere ma non è neanche brutto e
proprio e stranissimo cioè la cosa più
strana che abbia mai visto deve
scivolare sul sapone ma vabbè ma io ma
io sono estasiato da questa da cotanta
bellezza
no ero salvo maledizione è anche
difficile c'è anche un gioco con della
sfida sopra un incredibile
ok mi son sapere dove che sa sono in un
sottomarino perché c'è un quadro qua
sotto
devo fare qui salto raga non ho capito
aiuto mettici pure te è già un casino
sto gioco
porca vacca laida cosa devo fare qui a
c'è un'altra nave fa che bello sono
incastrato ma no dai
no mi rifiuto
mi sono incastrato tra la lampadina nel
coso della doccia aiuto a cagare vanno
dai raga la cosa più triste che abbia
mai visto sto gioco cioè cos'è è
talmente senza senso che non possono
giocarlo raga premessa sto gioco anche
pagato 4 euro quindi non ancora peggio è
la madonna quanto quanto world non vi so
veramente descrivere la difficoltà di
questo livello raga non riesco a
ucciderlo barbarossa pensio finalmente
un po dark souls devi sono inginocchiati
davanti a cotanta difficoltà io io non
ho veramente poi cos'è sta roba hubacher
ok a me lo ricordo da qua mi fate andare
avanti che bello
posso passare qui io muoio sono
estasiato da cotanta bellezza ragazzi
c'è veramente da darmi la spinta
oggi ho fatto perfetto occhio grazie a
dio la musica è finita perché ecco
perché c'è mia nonna che esce da non
riesco a menare la norma aiuto vabbè
lasciamo la lì c'è ma per fare il suo
gioco hanno preso delle foto di cos'è ma
basta la nonna pure dal pavimento hanno
preso una foto di è riuscito a uccidermi
ce non ho parole o ma basta
minchia veramente i boss rick di dark
souls possono accompagnare solo perfetto
si è sciolta la nonna ma non penso che
aveva mai giocato una roba così c'è loro
hanno fatto delle foto ha delle cose
vere tipo il frigo e l'hanno messo
dentro gioco cioè la grafica è a dei
livelli estremi
addirittura c'è la barra della vita
adesso anche queste sono le due tizi che
c'era all'inizio del gioco io vorrei
analizzare la situazione se me lo
permettete la prima a delle zampe di
gallina la seconda a una sigaretta al
posto delle braccia
nello store avevano visto descrivere sta
roba cioè che cosa sorry
non volevo se il gaza ed è così s'è
incazzato
devo nominare il bambino che mi gira con
la caramella
va bene c'era veramente ragazza arcsoft
se non è niente in confronto a
difficoltà visto gioco ok
finalmente oggi si integra tosco bambino
torino a posto che soddisfazione di
tutto quello che ho appena visto non so
descrivere una sega chimica sono state
un bio bio chiarissimo a ti sei [ __ ]
a brutta [ __ ] solo perché c'era la
ferrari è maledetto save the princess
salva la principessa ma com'e a sono io
da grande è quello di prima ero io bebè
adesso sono io da grande rinvio adesso
sono diventato grande mi riconosco
perché la stessa caramella di quando ero
bambino e devo salvare la mia ragazza
che è andata con uno che ci aveva più
soldi di me maledetto chi è questo che
spazza perché ci hai un mocio al posto
del piede con il prof
ai avafx ancora non c'è una ventina di
contro ci sto mettendo ad avvicinare la
sedia
ora come si avvicinava e vabbè ci se
vinci la lentissima ce lo spingo a una
velocità di un millimetro al secondo ok
madonna devi morire
ci ho messo un'ora fa sta roba basta
sì cosa devo cosa non ho capito
tutto quello che avete imparato in
fisica in questi anni lo prendetelo
buttate nel cesso tirate l'acqua due o
tre volte e poi ci cagate dentro accesso
e non la tirate più l'acqua non so
neanche descrivere sta roba ma cosa cosa
ho visto cioè far esplodere quali ci ho
messo un'ora e mezza a parte magazine
se sei veramente minaccioso perché si è
chiuso nell'armadietto oh mio dio ed è
pure riuscito a colpirmi come una vacca
gare difficilissimo devo mena
dopo meno agli armadietti non capitola
devo bloccare gli armadietti immagino
sempre con la mia forza da bruto nello
spingere le cose caso è difficile che
questo l'ho bloccato in teoria aia va a
cagare
ok ma anche all'ultimo in teoria era e
basta un'ora e mezza per era a cagare te
la tua macchina schifosa maledizione
qualche faccia che ciò io perché
io ho squartato il tizio e mi sono preso
un torso da tartaruga
beh ragazzi salto temporale nuovo vero
spero spero è perché non so sono più
adulto adesso chi di questi sono io
hai sempre la tizia perfetto casa cosa
mi devo aspettare la cresta roba vi
supplico ora sono io col dorso la
tartaruga perfect dance va bene devo
danza va bene ok va bene aiuta ma siete
pazzi ma se ed esce no no no no ve lo
spiego io ve lo dico se con tags non ce
la farò mai a fare una roba del genere
mai per me non puo finire qua c'e
veramente impossibile dovevo applicare
no siete dei deficienti che gli dovevano
cliccare no perchè se no al continuo a
fare sta roba era era volutamente
impossibile allora si michele
impossibile veramente l'aria diventa
sempre più brutto man mano che il cresco
presse z to work un dollaro
ma come hai ogni volta premo z
guadagniamo un dollaro va bene a 50
dollari
raggiungo il caffè accento raggiungo
flutter i che non solo sia a 800 usa la
testa era il caffè questo per 50 caffè
che non so che cosa sia frattari però
dove questo è il mio capo cinese
maledetto cazzo a 3.500 helping hand
venosi anche l'altra mano a 15.000
impiegato del mese fa bene forse la
testa chiarissimo e se voi vi chiedete
ma fa vincere come fai tu a montare i
tuoi video così un tutorial incredibile
perfetto impiegato nel mese 15.000
veloce e fattura ha ucciso il mio con il
collega alla mano che aiuta non era
l'altra mia mano era la mano del collega
va bene impiegato del mese abbia scelto
ammazzi tutti sei solo tu e rimasto
bravissimo ho guadagnato la mano e che
aiuta bene l'altro il cambio gap ancora
vivo non si sa come sei licenziato ma
cosa come sono licenziato dopo tutto
quello che ho fatto per te mi sono
impiantato una mano nella terra è coesa
potevi usare anche la mano della testa
in realtà è finito no non è finita no no
spesso 4 euro
in cella è finito veramente sta
scherzando cifra si faccia new game mimì
riprendimi riprenderà io che sono
bambino tu stai mi stai c'è uno schermo
pietro ci sei
no perché glielo devo consigliare
consigliamo agli amici giochi quelli che
meritano di micro qua compra
assolutamente live perché sono i 4 euro
meglio li ho spesi della mia vita ma che
cazzo ridi ero indeciso se dare 4 euro
agli zingari forse comprare sta roba è
ho comprato questo compra ora non te ne
pentirai no perché io voglio che le
altre persone siano complici della della
mia disgrazia perché non fosse sembrato
quando prendete tipo iii a scuola no
però l'ha preso anche il vostro compagno
di banco windy city almeno insieme nella
cattiva sorte no io qua sono da solo gli
ospiti sono gli osti 4 euro maledetti
almeno compratelo tu porca vacca poi non
mi piglia neanche sul serio sto
maledetto io non c'è veramente la gente
ogni cantoni cefali perché non porti
giochi più belli ma siete orgogliosi di
quello che di fatto sul canale vabbè
raga io spero che video vi sia piaciuto
come al solito il momento che mi piace
anche perché il mi piace merita sta roba
come si dice fiduciosa momento mi piace
anche vari social come nella descrizione
sono sicuri iscrivetevi e non ci vediamo
al prossimo video bella ragazzi
[Musica]